heads up guys my name is Jenna and
welcome to the fifth Sparky dev vlog so
last week we took a look at SPM tool and
SPM build tool and and how models kind
of work with in Sparky and I of course
added that whole custom model format and
and I began to show you guys where I was
at with physically based rendering and I
kind of showed off this demo I don't
really say much but today we're going to
die pretty deep into that when I see
exactly what I did with that I'm gonna
update you guys with what I'm currently
working on of course in typical devlog
fashion and just kind of cover what I've
been working on the last two weeks so
the first thing I want to do is is
probably talk about well I mean I guess
we'll start off with yeah I think I
think I'll just kind of start off with
PBR here and we'll see we'll see how we
go with all that stuff so the first
thing that I wanted to mention was I
think since the last dev'reaux really I
think it's been like it's been almost a
month actually I've pretty much been if
you do take a look at the github
repository for sparking you probably
weren't seeing any of these changes and
you might be surprised you might be like
well where is all of this code why is it
when when I download the this version of
Sparky I don't see any office physically
based rendering things like I don't I
open test three day and this is this is
not what I see why is that happening
well glad you asked the reason is that
I'm actually not using git for for kind
of really kind of fast iterations and
and really like what I'm actually
developing things all the time like when
I'm actively working on a new feature
instead of creating a branch in gears
like I used to do in the past I actually
use a separate version control system
called version I okay that's why you're
not seeing anything here so I showed you
I kind of showed you guys this last time
all the time before that like if we go
over here we have a command prompt and
we take a look at
the concise log you can kind of see what
I've been doing right so this is this
isn't even let's limit this to like 20
or something this isn't even that recent
but like if you look at the dates yeah
so basically all of February really I've
been working on all this kind of stuff
right so I finished the image by sliding
function we've have all this kind of PBR
work that's going on normal mapping got
added a bunch of really quite
interesting features right and I commit
these two version of because there is no
reason for these to be public ok these
are kind of and really like kind of this
is like my development cycle right I
also find version are a lot easier and
more reliable than than get to be honest
and that's kind of the reason that I use
it it also handles large files very very
well which is going to soon become a
problem when I start actually adding
adding resources as I am now in fact now
initially my plan was just to leave it
at that but you guys wanted me to
somehow give you access to this so what
I'm doing is I'm setting up a pretty
exclusive server that has all this stuff
in it right all of my kind of broken
nightly building and like you can see
these commits are like well it's like
four comments a day this stuff is pretty
frequent and all you have to do to get
access to that code is support Sparky on
patreon ok so if you get a patreon and
you pledge five dollars or more per
month then you get access to this
version of repository ok and you can
take a look at all the code when it's
still being developed by me
ok now this isn't for everyone I
probably wouldn't recommend this for
people who just want to jump into Sparky
and actually see stuff working but if
you want to be on the bleeding edge of
things you want to kind of see all the
stuff that gets added and of course it
is the repository so you'll be able to
see what I remove as well if you really
want to keep up to date here then that's
gonna be your best bet so this is only
for people who really want to kind of
jump in and and for Sparky very very
closely and support it ok if you guys
don't want to do that
fine it'll still be on github I'm
planning a release soon on github so
I'll update all of this stuff on to the
github repository but you can see right
now that if I actually do check for
modifications or something and get like
a lot of things have been modified since
I lost keep committed like a look at all
this look at all this that's not even
including stuff that I added like all of
this stuff this is all new so yeah if
you guys want access to that then
patreon is the way go ok cool that also
kinda gives me some support as well
obviously the reason I'm doing that is
because I want to spend more time
working on Sparky and with your support
that is very very possible ok cool so
let's focus on physically based
rendering the first thing I want to
mention is that I people have been
begging me for quite a while now to
actually kind of show you guys in my old
kind of tutorial fashion how to
implement all this stuff line by line ok
and my answer to that is I am totally
gonna do that ok once I get it down in
Sparky ok just drink its water that um
that's that's the important kind of part
of this right I I will do these
tutorials and I'll teach you guys how to
do this line by line I'll explain how
everything works but I really want to
get this right at first in Sparky
because I'm still experimenting with it
right I don't have a full PBR
implementation that I can just slap in
right now yeah I'm still kind of working
out what kind of values I want
everywhere and and what particular
models I actually want to use ok so it's
a bit difficult for me to do that
because I definitely am not comfortable
with teaching something that I'm still
very much researching so that's why you
guys aren't saying that so I am kind of
focusing on Sparky right now as you can
see and then once once I I am 100%
confident in my ability to implement PBR
I will start making videos on how you
guys can implement it for yourselves ok
definitely gonna happen so don't worry
about that
okay cool so let's start off here with
the top and we'll kind of go through
this test 3d thing it's about 300 lines
in fact it's exactly 300 lines so it's
not the smallest demo but it's it's it
definitely has a lot of redundant things
in it so don't worry too much about that
okay cool so let's see what happens here
so it's broken down into a few methods
yeah every every kind of layer has these
methods okay whether or not you actually
implement your own versions of them so
you override them or not that's your
choice but basically we have on event on
it on render on tick and on update again
in the constructor and destructor so the
idea is the three ones that we kind of
hear about on init on render and on
update all right on event is useful for
doing like key events and stuff but like
we're not even doing that stuff right
here anyway so it doesn't really matter
okay cool so yeah so with those three
methods though on init is where we kind
of initialize the game if I can remember
shortcut to collapse everything it gets
it's one of these here no maybe it's
control what is it remember here's an it
control although maybe it's old alright
I don't know there was a shortcut that
I've totally forgotten which just
basically collapses all the methods for
you anyway so yeah so on and it will
kind of run when the when the layout
gets initialized so this will happen
once think of this as like the
constructor except it will actually
happen when there is a renderer and a
scene already created okay on tick is
something that runs once per second so
it's it's really just useful for
printing out stuff like frame rate okay
we don't really need to be doing this
especially because we are displaying it
on the actual thing that's fine on
update is something that runs 60 times
per second no matter what your vsync is
and then on render is something that
runs in sync in sync with your monitors
refresh rate right so 60 Hertz or 60
frames per second
be kind of the the amount of times that
would get called on my monitor okay cool
whether or not that vsync is actually
accurate I'm not 100% sure I don't think
so I think it's just just set to 60 it's
just hard coded in there but future
proofing that that that is what that is
how often on render will happen so cool
and then on event of course gets called
whenever an event gets triggered that
hasn't already been handled by another
layer okay
so jumping into this the first thing we
do here is we basically load in a cube
map okay this is actually not the cube
mount we're using anymore I can probably
get rid of that this is the cube and
that we're loading now if we take a look
at this we're having the containing
folder here in fact I think I've already
got this open we can take a look at the
resources that we have here so this is
on the PBR cube map so we'll go into
there and what you're seeing here is 11
cube map images okay they're BMPs for no
particular reason
but basically what these guys are if I
just open this up it's gonna I really
wanted it to open and paint on that but
well if we open these up 11 all them up
my I'll show you guys will top oh that's
totally not what I wanted cancel anyway
why did that not just open them all a
separate there we go okay so basically
what you guys are seeing are MIT Maps
okay so this this is an ax vertical
cross format basically this is as my
selection thing this is the kind of y+
cube mount this is the one negative cube
mount this is the X negative x positive
Z positive and Zed negative now this
one's actually flipped it's kind of
upside down so this one actually needs
to be flipped both horizontally and
vertically when you load in
but anyway the idea is what we're seeing
here is a cube map now what did I get is
cube map from well that's a great
question that I wish I could answer but
I'm not sure let's quickly just see what
now I again this is something that I
will go into in depth in a dedicated
video so that you
you know how you can make your own cave
maps and all that stuff is Pocky so I
did tweet someone the link there so I'm
just gonna quickly find that tweet yeah
here it is so it's a really quite a good
resource called HDI labs calm and what
you'll find is called si BL right as
they call it smart I bill but basically
there are free hgri sets for image based
lighting right so if you if we quickly
look at this and I'm actually uploading
a video right now so that's why my
internet is extremely slow because I'm
using like all my bandwidth so I'll take
its opportunity to drink some water this
is gonna be quite a quite a long day
vlog because I want to kind of show off
the stuff that I've been working on so
hope you guys are okay with that all
right so this has a lot that there are
quite a lot of cute maps here now when
you download these they actually first
of all the thing you'll notice is they
are huge yeah you can see this one as it
says over here the resolution is 8,000
by 4,000 okay absolutely massive which
is great one of the things that you'll
notice is there actually lat/long images
so what i mean by that is i would
download one now but my internet is
terrible
basically hgri basically they look like
this right I'm actually not even sure if
this specifically in lat/long but they
kind of look like this so they don't
come in a cube mat form okay so you've
got a few options the best option is to
just find actual cube maps but I like
this is a good example of the different
formats you'll find so spherical is one
name for this well this vehicle can be
confused with kind of the light probe a
spherical because this is literally
sphere but lat/long or light longitude
is a good kind of thing so this is this
is what format those maps come in we
want them in a vertical or a horizontal
cross right they can also be separate
images for Sparkie so in order to do
that you have to convert it from this
format to this form
you will lose a little bit of data by
doing so but not not enough to really
notice because remember this is just a
this is just a cute map it's not really
it it's not like a texture that you'll
fall on view I mean obviously certainly
possible if you if you were reflecting
everything like a mirror but anyway the
point is you can convert this now I'm
using a tool called CM ft for that and
CM ft is right over here as a
cross-platform app and so it's it's
little command-line utilities got a GUI
as well but I personally don't like it
there's the cube a filtering tool this
fool it's very very fast it will convert
it'll convert the lat/long HDR kind of
images into cube maps for you into like
vertical cross cube maps it can also
generate MIT maps I haven't really I
haven't really experimented with this
generating MIT maps but I have been
using something called cube map gen
which is an ATI
kind of AMD little utility from a long
time ago that will basically take in
like it'll take in the vertical cross
that cm ft will generate right and it
will produce MIT maps for your cube map
so that instead of looking like this
where you can see the seams of the cube
map and I think I'm not sure if I show
that the devlog before last I don't
think I did but basically if you just
made map them yourselves or get OpenGL
to generate map MIT maps for you in fact
we can probably I can probably show you
what that looks like if we bring back
those ones and we say that environments
equals texture cube from files so files
and oh yeah so that should we'll see
what this does if it even works
okay cool it did so this is a different
cube man but basically the problem with
this one is that it's not met map
properly so whilst these ones will kind
of look okay and that is like I've been
seeing this a lot it's kind of white
specular I don't know what that is for
the specular is like up here anyway you
can see what this looks like
yeah it looks absolutely terrible at low
Maps okay and that's because obviously
if you're looking at something that is
literally our one by one cube map if all
faces like different colors or whatnot
it will look terrible
so what you need is you need to properly
filter your Maps
okay you can use something like the AMD
tool right the cube map gen that'll do
it for you okay you can load in that
Vettel cross that yet but possibly cmf
table though for you as well experiment
I will experiment with that more
throughout the week but the idea is you
can see how disgusting that looks this
is something like this right which looks
much much nicer okay there are still a
few visible seams that I again I
actually tweaked none of the settings in
the hue pumpkin at all I just literally
press filter and export because I didn't
have too much time but you can see
already it looks and looks a lot better
anyway okay cool so that's kind of the
idea behind cube maps I'm again they'll
probably be an in-depth kind of video
about them but that's just all you need
to know about how they work and that's
why I have several map maps yeah you can
see that texture cube from from multiply
sorry yeah for multiple files that just
calls GL generate MIT map which is kind
of okay for textures like fridges 2d
textures but of course cube maps when
you have long lips in your sampling
you'll get corners and you'll get those
seams so it yeah it's not really
something you want to do for that and so
you can see that what happens here is
when we load it from the cross thing we
we kind of set each map separately okay
so that's something that that happens
there okay cool so then we create a
bunch of materials let's take a look at
what the materials actually look like
I'm using something called quick soul
which is a photoshop plugin
that I'll probably show you guys how I
use that in some other dedicated video
man this is gonna spawn off so many
videos I'm sure you guys will be happy
seeing them but let me know if you are
hyped for like videos on like 10
different subjects so if we look at
something like cast iron Knight great
example let's look at something like
Warren wood ok so what we have here is a
bunch of maps ok you can include all the
glass a bit for now so basically we have
a PBR material is made up of usually
around 4 textures it can be a lot more
but we in Sparky are currently using
four textures those are required ones ok
you don't really need to have them I've
always developed Sparky with the
mentality of it should be easy to use
thus as soon as someone wants to quickly
create them in like a sandbox kind of
thing and they just want to see a cube
they shouldn't have to go out and make
four textures for it to even render ok
that's silly so there are kind of two
options there are defaults which I which
don't exist yet but there will be
defaults for pretty much everything but
other than that you can either set a
texture or a color ok so you can set a
constant color as like one of these PBR
textures right so if you want like say
the LB entire specular to be a single
color you can just set a color you don't
have to set a texture ok or you can set
a texture if you want to okay so the
ones we're seeing here are so the albedo
looks like this the albedo is diffused
ok that's what I'll be that means it's
just a diffuse color so this is the kind
of color of healthy surface so to speak
right this is what it looks like for
this particular material if we look at
something like what the gun what
gunmetal looks like and again these are
all materials generated from quitzel
which is a very very good little utility
which I definitely recommend because
it's kind of like substance painter and
substance designer I guess but a lot
easier to use and it's great for quick
materials you guys probably know idea
what I'm talking about but basically
what quick cyl is is a plugin for
Photoshop which will let will kind of
generate these maps for you and they
have like a hundred presets okay and
this is one of them so that's kind of
where I'm getting these from okay I'm
not making them myself or anything but
when the page loads you'll kind of see
what clicks all is man multitasking
today uploading a video recording a
video while top loading ends up with the
really really slow internet which is fun
it's what it's like to live in Australia
where our upload speeds are horrific
alright so this is what quick so is I'm
actually just gonna probably not yeah
not literally shows you what it is but
that this is what I'm talking about okay
clicks so sweet too
so you can use something like DDO
painter or what the D do painter and
three do north radio which will kind of
just preview everything for you but
basically you can select from a bunch of
presets and then generate textures from
them which is what I've done okay cool
unknown again they'll be a standalone
video for that eventually alright so
yeah if we look at the con metals albedo
for example you can see this is just
completely black this is just a solid
colors don't really you can see there
are a few scratches in the texture and
that's fine so that's the albedo alright
if we were to I might actually just if I
pop over into my shader I could just
show you show you guys these things kind
of separately so if I just set the color
to yellow better
then you'll see you will see the albedo
of every kind of surface okay so you can
see that there are a lot of kind of
black albedo's out there I'm not using
anything like wormwood anyway if I was
you would see that out that albedo's so
if I change that that cube to use
wormwood then you can see there that's
kind of that albedo right here alright
cool
sorry if we look at the next extra so
where are we paint on that okay the next
one that will probably look
specula the specular map is sorry that's
for gunmetal that's what it looks like
for gunmetal this kind of will just
define the specular color essentially so
if we go over to where are my Warren
would specular alright you can see this
is I think pretty sure this is just as a
solid color so having a kind of having a
low kind of specular color so you can
see obviously this color is like what is
it yes it's quite dark right it's
something it's like 46 46 46 so that
will result in kind of a dimmer specular
right so again if we kind of view that
for everything material specular which
is a vector E then that's kind of what
we are seeing okay and we'll talk about
the plane probably later but you can see
the specular colors of all that one
thing that's cool to note is you can see
the plastic balls have a lower specular
whereas the the metal balls have a high
specular that's kind of how metal works
in the real link in the real world
basically so metal will have a very very
black kind of albedo I say very black
because it's not completely black but a
very very black albedo and a very white
specular okay and these are actually
just constant values for the spheres
here they're actually maps right they're
textures but here they're constant
values cool so that's good and you can
see by the way that if like we can
change these a bit later on and I'll
show you how that works as well I guess
we look at the gloss which is really
just one channel you can see that it's
very very low here it's got kind of
color variations right but it's very
very black which means that the surface
is not reflective so if we look at the
roughness so roughness is basically
gloss it's basically one minus gloss
right that is what
roughnesses so it's just the inverse of
gloss so roughness is what I use in all
my equations so if we look at that and
I'll just set let's see this is a bit
annoying but we'll do something like
that
just want the Alpha to be one then you
can see what the roughness looks like so
there's fine this is why it which means
it's completely rough and you can see
obviously the very roughnesses of these
balls all right cool
that's our office map so that that
basically defines over here is actually
a gloss map so this is actually 1 -
roughness right so basically if
something's black or something's dark it
means it's not very reflective okay
whereas if something is white if the
gloss map would be white then it would
be quite reflective all right and you
can see if that roughness eventually is
used in primarily whilst using the
specular equation but it's primarily
kind of important for stuff like IBL as
well because it defines for example
which mid-level we sample because the
basically the idea is the more rougher
texture is the kind of lower resolution
copy it gets of the world because it's
reflecting less anyway not going to go
into the theory here but the idea is
that's what our offices and then finally
we've got the normal map all right and a
normal map is pretty basic ok it
essentially all it is of course is just
a a modification to our vertex normals
right to give a bit more detail and that
of course is just using light equations
the color determines which way the
normals are facing for that particular
fragment so if we just look at that and
all of that is probably too interesting
but we actually can't even look at that
because hello may we can we can look at
the normals that it generates so
there we go whoops there is a semi gone
in there all right so these are the
normals that we kind of get as a result
of that normal map all right you can see
it in there okay cool I think the same
normal map is being applied to pretty
much everything except for this cube all
right cool
so data that is all the different maps
and if we render them all together using
that one would kind of thing for that
cube then you should see something that
looks a little bit like wood okay I've
actually turned off the normals there
which is why everything is very very
smooth but this is basically what's
supposed to be wooden weather on it is
is probably dependent on my actual
calculations which I have not proof read
100% I'm not a hundred percent satisfied
they're actually correct in my shadow so
I definitely need spend more time there
so don't yell at me if something doesn't
look quite like it should because it's
very possible that that will be a case
but if we put the whole map back on
perhaps this will look a little bit more
like wood so yeah I'm seeing kind of
some really bright areas which look do
look a bit weird which I still need to
probably work on anyway
kind of looks like a wooden block I
wouldn't I wouldn't argue too much with
that anyway that's kind of how that
works now say I wanted since I am using
a we go back to test 3d and we look at
the actual material that we're using for
that block oh yeah yes so basically we
set up our materials just let me finish
my first thought we set up out all of
our materials and then we create bunch
of models and entities which use those
materials all right this or these two
things kind of just create our spheres
all right and then we create that plane
and see we set our lights and shadows
which we don't actually render because
I've turned that off for now all right
cool then that's pretty much this entire
thing and there are a few things here
that just update certain transforms
because of course we have those debug
menu hookups that we use to modify stuff
it in real time which I don't actually
I'm using right now anyway that's kind
of how the rest of this test works sir
when I correct the cube I create a new
material instance let's kind of bring
this out so we can kind of play around
with it sir
cube material I'll call it so have my
material instance called cube material
how long is this going to fall 28
minutes incredible all right
we've got this cute material we can kind
of override certain things so we can say
that instead of using because what
happens is this cube material is it's a
material instance that gets created from
a material right and the actual material
is worn what is this one right you can
see what's happened is that material has
an environment map and for kind of other
maps right albedo expect to look Lawson
normals all right
so we can of course in the material
instance set these two other things and
it will only apply for that material
instance so if I set the cube materials
albedo you can see I can choose between
an albedo map or a just an albedo color
but let's do something more interesting
like gloss I can set the gloss to be one
right which would mean that it's super
super reflective and if I take a look at
what that would look like you can see
how now we are basically reflecting
everything the normals are pretty up
there so you can see the reflections are
not clear or anything but we can see
kind of how this is much more reflective
now kind of like what this Jenner thing
on the ground is very very very
reflective okay so that's an example the
other thing we could do is actually
modify the map so if we take a look at
gloss for example which is this one I
could just take a fairly large brush
here and that's not even that large and
it may be select white and just kind of
draw something here right and then if I
save that and we take a look at our cube
again then you can see that kind of
areas of the cube look like they're very
very reflective and areas don't
all right and then there's there's that
thing now the actual UV unwrapping is
probably very weird for this model
because I didn't do it all so we are
rendering back faces that's fun but
basically yeah you can see kind of what
I did with that mouth cool and we can
even do some probably really weird
things with that such as perhaps running
a gradient through it like that again
never try this actually so I don't know
what this will look like that
should be fun all right so looks like
the ways of the way that the UV unwraps
is kind of making this look like one
face is very reflective and one isn't
it'll probably be then the normals are
quiet
the normals are quiet kind of harsh you
can see for this texture so if I turn
the normals off and we'll be able to see
their reflection and stuff very very
clearly as if this was a mirror so you
can see that this part is kind of
gradient II kind of looks quite cool
actually and then this one's just not at
all you can see in the channel as well
we can kind of see the environment very
clearly which is kind of cool all right
anyway
that's kind of what that looks like I'm
also gonna do here yeah I was actually
going to try and so if we go into our
custom material I called it which is
that one that has China written on it
and all that stuff and we look at the
glass if I replace this glass with a
gradient and saved us let's take a look
at this I'm just curious more than
anything now it's quite fun to play with
okay that's interesting
so Wow okay so yeah you can see this
side is barely reflective and then as we
get more here we get way more reflective
so it's kind of cool
and then there's I also wrote try now
and specular which is why you're still
seeing it yeah that's actually very very
weird
anyway that's that's that okay that is
basically what I've done over the past
few weeks or wait and a half I think so
yeah still kind of tweaking it still
fixing it but that is kind of the gist
of off Sparky PBR so it's coming along
nicely obviously needs a lot of tweaking
in some cases but more or less it looks
pretty good as soon as it does start
looking great and also the other thing
we can probably do which I should have
mentioned is we can change the light
direction and you can see how that kind
of changes of course a specular and all
that stuff
I quite quite like these these cubes
they've got that they've got a cast iron
normal mapping on on them by the way
which is the cast iron material so it
looks like this just pretty pretty crazy
that's why you're seeing that but they
still look quite nice so yeah once I
kind of wrap this up apart from making
videos on how it works I'll probably
start trying to actually create a proper
scene that probably will be a good time
to start writing a level editor as well
for Sparky but that's a lot of work so I
don't know if I can be bothered doing
that I might just say everything in code
I'll probably end up putting something
like lower into the engine as well to
make this a bit easier I did put in
reloadable shaders as well so if you hit
the are key we'll just reload your
current shader so that's nice what else
did I do that's about it so that's gonna
wrap up as devlog thanks for watching
guys again if you do want to stay up to
date with the code then patreon.com for
such the Cherno there'll be a link in
description you can get access to the
version repository there apart from that
yeah just follow me on Twitter I usually
post a lot of pictures of Sparky for
example if you look at my feed recently
you can see I kind of posted all these
kind of screenshots of what I was doing
and speaking of staying up to date as
well slack is a fantastic little
resource for that as well so there's a
Sparky channel on my slack page
and if you go over here I'm I kind of
somewhat treat this like my kind of
devlog or rather like a like a little
blog like a development blog so I post
like pictures here all the time and I
talk to people and we discuss things and
it's a really good it's a quite a nice
place to be so if you want to join there
that you just have to go to the channel
calm interview room enter your email
address and you'll be able to join the
slack and join the Sparkie channel okay
of course there are a lot of other
channels for stuff like journals talk
and C++ and Java and all that stuff but
Sparkie of course is real uh fit into
these pocket game engine alright guys
thanks for watching and I'll see you
next time goodbye